for the night is dark and
full of terrors in the ancient books
it's written that a warrior will draw a
burning sword from the fire
and that sword shall be lightbringer
prophecies are dangerous things hi
everyone it's charlie this is going to
be my video explaining what's going on
with azor ahai on the tv series what
they've changed from the books because
there are a couple retcons in the last
couple of episodes with arya stark's
character there are a lot of you that
are confused does this mean that she's
azor ahai now
so we'll try to explain what's going on
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the game of thrones
videos there's a new round of the hbo
now giveaway to all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
obviously careful for spoilers through
season 8 episode 3 if you have not seen
the episode yet because we'll be talking
about what happened at the end of it
after the episode a lot of people were
wondering if arya stark is now supposed
to be the real azor high
per the show's explainer because she's
the person that landed the killing blow
on the night king
so then what does it mean that
melisandre has been talking about the
prince who was promised azor ahai this
whole time ever since she debuted during
season 2
then even if you haven't read the books
they use season 7 episode 2 to introduce
the concept that high valyrian is a
gender-neutral language
so it could also be interpreted as the
princess who was promised will be the
one who will bring the dawn
there are a couple different concepts
tied up in this prophecy there's azor
ahai in the prince or now princess who
was promised but those are really the
same thing pulling from the exact same
prophecy
it's just that in the series and in the
books melisandre tends to use the term
azor ahai
more often than not whereas other
characters like maester aemon in the
books and rhaegar targaryen
used the prince who was promised when
talking about the prophecy
the text of the prophecy that melisandre
keeps quoting from just reads
there will come a day after a long
summer when the star bleeds and the cold
breath of darkness falls heavy on the
world
in this dread hour a warrior shall draw
from the fire a burning sword and that
sword
shall be lightbringer the red sword of
heroes and he who clasps it shall be
azor ahai
come again in the darkness shall flee
before him
we kind of got a version of that at the
beginning of season two with stannis
because at that time she thought that
stannis was the fulfillment of the
prophecy
she'd been seeing visions in the flames
but as we learned later in the series
her ability works a lot like bran
stark's ability where she's getting all
this information but she doesn't
necessarily know how to contextualize it
so her visions are now
starting to come true at the end of the
series it's just that early in the game
she didn't know exactly when
these things were going to happen like
when stannis was getting ready for the
battle of winterfell and melisandre
burned shireen because she was convinced
that that was the battle that she had
been seeing in her visions
he would be victorious the prince who
was promised as we later learned that
was
false the battle that she had been
seeing this whole time in the flames
was this battle of winterfell against
the night king and the white walkers
so when you think about melisandre's
visions early in the series and how she
was wrong later just think about her the
same way you think about bran like just
has all this information doesn't know
quite what to make of it has trouble
contextualizing it and placing it in the
timeline
so azor ahai is just one of many
prophecies in the books george r martin
is much bigger about
seeding in prophecies into the narrative
than the tv show has been so the tv show
has cut out a whole bunch of stuff like
you talk about maggie the frog
the prophecy of the valonqar the tv show
completely cut that out
so when we're talking about the tv show
paying off big prophecies you really
just have to think about the prophecies
that they've literally said out loud so
azor ahai
just happens to be one of the few that
they've actually talked about on the
series
if you remember season seven episode two
like that added wrinkle oh it could
actually be the princess who was
promised maybe daenerys is the
fulfillment of the prophecy
with jon snow because melisandre senses
that jon
is very important in the war for the
dawn she just doesn't know exactly what
he's supposed to do
and because of what happened with
shireen she's learned to be more
cautious about the way she interprets
her visions in the flames
like she says prophecy is a tricky thing
and kind of shakes her head a little bit
like
don't hold me hard and fast to this i'm
not telling you exactly what needs to
happen i'm just telling you that you
and jon snow are both very important to
this prophecy
in the books that's probably going to be
a wins of winter type moment but the way
they're seeing it is actually through
maester aemon's character
maester aemon in the books is also
thinking about the prophecy of the
prince who was promised he believes in
it the way that rhaegar believes in it
he corresponded with him regularly
based on what the books tell us rhaegar
was obsessed with prophecy daenerys even
has a vision of him
quoting the prince who was promised when
at the time rhaegar actually thought
that it was his son with elia martel
named aegon targaryen
the reason why rhaegar thought that this
aegon the son of elia martel was the
fulfillment of the prophecy is
because he was born as a red comet was
over king's landing so the whole idea is
that the comet is very important to this
azor ahai figure so just remember when
that was happening on the tv show that
was near the time when daenerys's
dragons were hatched
so she was reborn amidst salt and smoke
also
jon snow was at the fist of the first
men with the wildlings
learning about the threat of the white
walkers while that was happening but
early on the books and the tv show are
trying to tell you that there's no one
specific interpretation no one specific
person who is actually going to be azor
ahai it's probably going to be a number
of people working together
george r martin has talked a lot about
his original main characters before he
changed his story like i said arya stark
very important to his original end game
he originally intended to age the
characters up with a huge
time jump during the series whereas what
ended up happening is is that got
cancelled so arya stark kind of got
parked in braavos to learn
to become this crazy assassin as part of
the faceless men in the house of black
and white
not just to make a really badass face
stealing assassin obviously it was very
important for endgame that she have a
lot of these skills so even though the
tv show has changed a lot of things and
it's even retconned itself with a couple
of the aria stark moments during season
three which i'll explain in a second
there are a couple moments that happen a
couple lines of dialogue that melisandre
quotes which are actually retcons to
what she said earlier on the series
one of the other big changes from the
books is that there is no official night
king
as of yet in the books george r martin
has talked about a mythical
night's king plural night's king who was
the 13th lord commander of the night's
watch
a stark of winterfell who fell in love
with this ice bride
and was turned into what seems like a
white walker and turned on the brothers
of the night's watch
who then had to band together with the
king beyond the wall at the time of the
wildlings to defeat them and put them
back down
that was after the mythical long night
that people talk about the never ending
night that lasted for a generation which
is
about 8 000 years ago in the books more
recently he's been saying is closer to
four or five thousand years just because
there's no real recorded history from
that period the maesters didn't exist
the citadel wasn't a big thing until
much much later so like during season
eight episode two they talk about how
the night king is trying to eliminate
memory of man how do you keep people
from forgetting things you write it down
that's what the maesters are all about
so george r martin is just saying that
it's important not to take things too
literally when people are talking about
legends
of the long night and things that
happened during then because a lot of
the actual facts could have been twisted
over time
and a lot of that gets into the idea of
this azor ahai figure the person who
will bring the dawn
so here's lomas longstrider who wrote a
book within the context of a song of ice
and fire called wonders made by
man he talks about meeting descendants
of the rhoynar in the ruins of the
festival city of kroyan
who have tales of a darkness that made
the roin dwindle and disappear
her waters frozen as far south as the
joining of the cell horu
it goes on to say according to these
tales the return of the sun only came
when a hero
convinced the mother roy's many children
lesser gods such as the crab king and
the old man of the river to put aside
their bickering and joined together to
sing
a secret song that brought back the day
that sounds very similar to the legends
about the children of the forest coming
together with the first men to defeat
the night king and the white walkers
which we actually know are a real
thing melisandre comes from asshai so no
surprise that the legend of azor ahai
comes from that city so when she's
talking about stannis and then jon snow
she's talking about azor ahai come again
she's talking about this mythical figure
that came from
that part of the world not someone who
necessarily originated in westeros which
is where the mythical long night that we
keep talking about happened
there's another tale from something
called the jade compendium a book within
a song of ice and fire that recounts a
legend from et which is sort of an
analog for china within a song of ice
and fire
which states that the sun quote-unquote
hit its face from the earth for a
lifetime
ashamed it's something none could
discover in that disaster was averted
only
by the deeds of a woman with a monkey's
tail that all comes from george r martin
in the book so he's just trying to see
the idea that prophecy as melisandre on
the tv show says
is a tricky thing what it seems like is
that you have a lot of different
cultures
banding together putting aside their
differences to overcome
this big insurmountable threat so the
whole idea of azor ahai is tied up in a
bunch of
important people coming together to say
defeat the white walkers and the night
king or if the nike doesn't exist in the
book than just the white walkers
and on top of that too the mythical
figure is or high that's talked about in
these legends is also referred to as
quote unquote the last hero legends in
the north also state that this
mythical last hero figure and his
companions went in search of the
children of the forest during the long
night
thousands of years ago they survived
attacks by giants whites and the white
walkers
eventually they reached the children of
the force gained their assistance
they formed the night's watch and then
they had the battle for the dawn that
ended the long night so the path of the
last hero sounds a lot like what bran
stark did going north of the wall
seeking out the children of the forest
in the three-eyed raven seeking to renew
their alliance
jon snow also did similar things arya
stark traveled all over the world
gaining all these skills
and what she thought was to become a
faceless person jack and hagar always
implied that he knew a little bit more
about the path she was destined for than
he let on
so just more evidence of martin being
purposefully ambiguous about who this
one figure was
applying it to a bunch of different
characters in present day trying to let
you know that it's no real
one person that's doing all this by
themselves we still don't quite know if
martin is ever going to introduce a
night king-like figure that is an
original creation of the tv show but it
was introduced as an idea
when george r martin was still writing
game of thrones episodes so it's
something that he signed off on
i think the idea of a lot of these main
characters like jon snow daenerys arya
stark and some of the others being the
fulfillment of the prophecy
together collectively works better if
you have
numerous threats that you have to take
down all these white walkers instead of
just one main white walker
so some of the changes that the tv show
has made are incongruous with what
martin's trying to seed in the books so
it's kind of messing
with people's heads when it comes to
predicting who is azor ahai like are you
trying to tell me it's this one figure
jon snow this whole time oh now you're
trying to tell me it's both jon snow and
daenerys together then why is arya stark
technically the person to kill the night
king
because if it's got to be a prince or
princess who was promised how is arya
stark a princess
even though rob stark was briefly the
king in the north she's his sister so
maybe that would make her a princess and
that would kind of fulfill that part of
the prophecy
but how does it work does their special
blood exist even if they were only king
for a brief period
the whole idea is that martin is trying
to say don't put too much
faith in the letter of those prophecies
it's more about a broad interpretation
of what it really means them coming
together to defeat this threat as a
collective group
the thing that the tv show has done
which sort of misleads you along the way
is try to seed in clues like born under
a star where you see jon snow being born
in this bed where you have the star of
arthur dane's sword dawn
above the bed here's where the tv show
gets really tricky and it gives you an
idea that they didn't completely know
what the ending was going to be
when they seeded some of these earlier
easter eggs so you can't necessarily say
that they had this plan
the whole time during the episode
melisandre gives arya stark that pep
talk and reminds her about the prophecy
that she gave her earlier on the series
you said that we would meet again
i saw darkness in you and in that
darkness eyes staring back at me brown
eyes
green eyes blue eyes eyes you'll shut
forever
so what happens is in this moment they
wanted melisandre to give arya the idea
or remind her oh blue eyes blue eyes
like the night king i should go kill him
now
but the problem with this moment is that
it's actually a retcon to what the
actual prophecy she gave her during
season 3 was
so during season 3 episode 6 she says i
see a darkness in you and in that
darkness eyes staring back at me
brown eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes
will set forever
so the order of the colors of i she
would shut was different
here's the other big change they made
too they said that they decided that
arya would be the person to kill the
night king about three years ago which
is when they were getting ready to write
season seven so during season seven
that's why you saw samwell look at a
dagger in a book that looked exactly
like arya's dagger
they wanted to see the idea that the
dagger would be important for defeating
the night king so that's why bran
put it in her hands he sensed because of
his green site the dagger would be
important and she was the person to have
it he didn't know exactly when it would
be important
just that it would be important for arya
to have the dagger but like i said they
retconned the moment for arya when she
was getting ready to go kill the night
king so during season three when they
originally seated that prophecy which
actually is not from the books that's a
moment that the tv show made up
they did not know that arya stark would
be the person to kill the night king so
when she gave her the prophecy for the
first time that actually on the tv show
just referred to her stealing faces all
the people she'd be killing
she killed walder frey we talk about
arya shutting green eyes
cersei has emerald eyes in the books
lena heady has green eyes in real life
so keep in mind that while the tv show
is trying to wrap up the fulfillment of
a lot of things that it's been setting
up they will also probably retcon some
other moments from earlier in the series
and from the books so that it all just
seems to fit together by the end
so just because arya stark kills the
night king in this moment
doesn't mean that she is azor ahai so
given all that i think the best answer
to who azor ahai really is is actually
jon snow daenerys and arya stark
together you could argue that jaime
lannister
other characters have a role in helping
them along the way but i still think
that it's mostly about jon snow coming
together with daenerys
and arya stark being the person with the
skills to land some of these killing
blows
but when it comes to this moment in the
books i do think the actual
battle with the white walkers will go
down very differently so we'll just have
to check back after winds of winter
comes out to see if it goes down that
because the final book dream of spring
is supposed to be about what happens
after you defeat that threat like the
realm turn on itself will they put aside
their differences will old entities rise
back
up that's why you see them defeating the
night king in episode 3
because the rest of the story the dream
of spring of it all is going to be what
happens after the next couple of
episodes
so hopefully that explains a little bit
about the mythology behind this and some
of the changes that the tv show made
interesting to note about some of the
retcons too i might do another game of
thrones bonus video before episode 4
happens but my episode 4 video will post
sunday night just like normal as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see the videos when i post them
no worries
while you wait for everything click here
for my season 8 episode 4
trailer video and click here for my game
of thrones season 8 episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you